vous avez plus de vingt ans vous vous
souvenez forcément de caméra café
bondam coup recul de la chaîne m6 qui
entre 2001 et 2004 a dépeint l'univers
parfois peu reluisants de l'entreprise
je sais que vous avez pacifier les
comptes de la direction eric rey
incarnée par bruno solo et yvan le
bolloc'h qui dans le rôle de hervé
dumont et jean claude convenant nous en
ont fait voir de toutes les couleurs
surtout d'un point de vue vestimentaire
brève union ça va qu'il atterrit avait
tenté une seconde saison avec un autre
casting
le projet avait été rapidement laissé de
côté pourquoi moi fait chier mais en
attente offre qu'aujourd'hui près de 16
ans après l'arrêt de la série bruno solo
a annoncé le grand retour de caméra café
un retour ou presque car une nouvelle
saison n'est pas envisagée il s'agit
d'un numéro hommage pour raconter le
parcours de deux personnages depuis
l'arrêt du programme
bruno solo s'explique les pas question
de relancer la série a pris genou en
tout cas dans notre esprit rentrée pour
m6 après c'est à eux de décider dans
notre idée ce serait 1 ou 2 x 52 minutes
vous savez avec une sorte entracte à ou
1 90 minutes sur voilà en septembre 2021
si la série originelle avait duré cinq
cent soixante et onze numéros et attirer
du monde avec des records allant jusqu'à
5,6 millions de téléspectateurs
reste à savoir si ce retour sera gagnant
parce que c'était pour montrer qu'on
était sur le point que alors caméra café
le retour de la mini série culte bonne
idée alors le retour de caméra café
bonne mauvaise idée excusez moi mais
j'étais très fan de la série à l'époque
mais le problème c'est que on a tous
gardé des critères qu'on avait à
l'époque et qui ont sûrement mal vieilli
avec les années donc moi je préfère
garder des bons souvenirs de cette série
que retrouver voilà une amertume quand
je vais retrouver les acteurs donc à mon
avis pour moi ça marchera pas alors vous
avez quand même ce que ce qui va se
passer avec la série culte les biens
mais camelot c'est pas pareil avec frais
une réunion cinéma de bel-air d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qui dit j'ai lu tout ça n'a
pas de sens éditoriale c'est juste du
marketing faire éventuellement un coup
on peut pas être et avoir été ce sont
des mauvaises idées fête va essayer de
mettre de remettre au goût du jour
quelque chose qui est passé j'adore
bruno solo je ne comprends vraiment pas
le projet de tekken très jeune arthur tu
as connu l'époque de oui bah oui mes
parents et mes tessa la télé on
mon agent et oui moi je trouve que c'est
une bonne idée que ça revienne parce que
je pense que ça va rappeler des bons
souvenirs à certaines personnes c'est
une fois et que c'est pas tout une
saison complète je pense que ça peut
être sympa oui si arthur clavier je suis
désolé parce que caméra café c'était
parfait c'était vraiment c'était parfait
c'était dans l'imaginaire collectif c
c'était une super série et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les créateurs de friends
que vous citiez ne vote pas faire de
nouveaux épisodes parce qu'ils disent
comme le truc était parfait on va être
attendu au tournant et on fera forcément
quelque chose qui n'atteindra pas les
attentes des timbres appelle les
attentes des gens et j'ai un peu par
chaussade même si je les adore vraiment
et je suis en admiration devant eux
j'ai trop peur d'être déçu on ne
touchait pas ce truc parfait